pandas are majestic eaters of bamboo and
very good as sleeping for long periods
of time but they also have a secret
power chomping down on large datasets
today we'll introduce one of the most
powerful and popular tools in data
wrangling and it's called pandas when
you think of data science pandas is
probably not the first thing that comes
to mind these black and white bears
spend most of their time eating bamboo
and sleeping not doing data science but
today we'll use pandas to manipulate our
data sets and set it up for machine
learning I can't do the entire library
justice in just one video but hopefully
this overview will help you get going
and I'll leave it to you to explore the
fascinating world of pandas in more
depth
pandas is an open-source Python library
that provides easy to use high
performance data structures and data
analysis tools cuddly bears aside the
name comes from the term panel data a
common term for multi-dimensional data
sets encountered in both statistics and
econometrics to install pandas simply
run pip install pandas inside your
Python environment then we can import
pandas as PD one of the most common
things that pandas ends up being used
for is reading in CSV files using the
read CSV function it is often the
starting point for using pandas pandas
loads this data into a data frame this
can be thought of as essentially a table
or spreadsheet we can take a quick
glimpse of our data by calling head-on
our data frame data frames have rows of
data with named columns which empandas
are called series for me one of the
nicest things about data frames is the
described function which displays a
table of statistics about your data
frame this is super useful for sanity
checking your dataset seeing if the
distribution of your data looks
reasonable and whether the properties
are what you expect them to be I also
sometimes we use pandas to shuffle my
data this can be useful in situations
where you want to shuffle the entire
data set rather than merely having a
look ahead buffer as you extract it out
for example if your data is natural
little and in fact already sorted you
want to give it an extra good mixing
however for truly huge datasets it's
possible that this may be impractical
without more sophisticated approaches to
access a particular column of a data set
use bracket notation to pull out column
passing in the name of that column if
you're wondering what the possible
column names are you can look back at
the output of describe or use DF or data
frame columns to access all the columns
in the data frame as an array if you can
access data column by column then the
next thing you'll want to know is how to
access it by row accessing rows of data
frames is a little bit different than
from columns for example if we want the
row with an index I of a given data
frame we can use I lock or I location
index location at high keep in mind that
pandas operates on a zero-based indexing
system so the first row is actually
index is zero sometimes you may want a
particular row and column because rows
and columns are accessed differently
we'll need different techniques to get
that done in particular if you want row
five of a column called name you would
use something like this and where things
get much more interesting is when you
want to get a whole range of columns and
rows on the column side the way to get
multiple columns is to pass in an array
of those column names if there are many
many columns and you don't want to type
them all out you can use the columns
array the dot columns array and select a
range of column names from there and use
that to select columns if we want to get
a range of rows we can use colon
notation inside the brackets that follow
I lock like so and the starting index
here is included while the ending index
is excluded so this will return row
indices 5 6 7 8 and 9 but not row index
10 say we wanted both both a subset a if
columns and a subset of rows what would
that look like well we can combine what
we've learned so far and make one
expression that gets the job done
so first we'll choose the column names
just like we did before then we get the
columns back and then we can select the
rows from that data frame using that
colon notation and so once you get the
hang of things you'll actually be able
to collapse these three lines down into
just one expression something like this
and if this is the first time you're
seeing this sort of collapsing I'd
encourage you to pause here and look at
how this expression is exactly
equivalent to what we showed earlier
I'll still be here when you get back so
happy to wait we've looked at some
simple data manipulation in this video
and there's much more that the pandas
ecosystem offers from this efficient
file storage in the form of pie tables
and HDFS to running certain statistical
analyses now this has been just a quick
overview of what pandas can do so check
out the documentation links below to
start your journey of pandas thanks for
watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures be sure to subscribe to the
channel to check out future episodes
right when they come up for now get out
there tribe hand is in the wild